There are a lot of people around the sea who are just saying that they are ad-requesting guitars. The
old ones are treasures, so it's different if you don't use other things.
[Music] The
name is a building and Ryoichi. As a child who doesn't work in the rain, it's Hoshi.
Ando It's a
delusion that it's only in this Noto Peninsula, not anywhere in the world. It's a delusion that it's only in this Noto Peninsula.
I wonder if it was made in Japan, but
[Music] The
first morning, I came here from around 4:30
[Music]
I wanted Mars to worry about the number of
times, and he called the number of Heisei times.
Most of the time we're listening to the sponsorship of 100
tsubo, with the enhancement of 70 liters, that's about 19 cases,
1 book, 2 roles, and about
129.  After putting it in the music, pour water from above
again to concentrate the salt that
adheres to it.  I think that the sightseeing music will be messed up. If
6 people with heavy traffic are packed in the part, the 600 liters will be disclosed unless they work for a week
.
I lived there while living there.
The master of Mt. Ann uses seawater, so it's a show used for cooking. The
taste is mellow and salty, and the texture is smooth and the best for me.  It's okay, but
I wonder if it's the most suitable for Niimi.
[Music]
Everyone has a tendency to seek conventions, so there are two places in the year.
I think I can get about 12 tons. I've been able to do it since I was a
tiny child
.